deux ministres à la relance pour le
gouvernement c'est bien ici qu'il doit
se trouver l'eurobond dans les
industries avec des sites clés en main
comme sonnés or à chalon des sites déjà
bien équipée accessible mais dans
lesquels tout va plus vite permis de
construire en trois mois
autorisations environnementales en 9 2 à
4 fois plus vite que la normale car
l'urgence est bien à l'emploi notre
boussole c'est l'emploi industriel parce
que derrière un emploi industriel vous
avez 3 à 4 emplois induits
donc c'est essentiel pour les
territoires ça fait pas les gros
contingent d'emplois mais derrière ça
fait la création de richesse sur
l'ensemble des territoires il s'attire
l'ensemble de l'économie
et si le gouvernement a choisi suneor
c'est qu'à chalon on connaît la relance
sur ses terres on a reconstruit après
l'effondrement de kodak
avec désormais 350 entreprises sur la
zone 6000 emplois dont sgt une
entreprise de plasturgie qui est arrivé
l'an passé car justement l'implantation
a été facilitée c'est un gain de temps
et un montant très important si on ne
veut pas passer à côté des problèmes
environnementaux des problèmes
écologiques des problèmes archéologiques
il faut absolument que c'est comment
dire ces études là soit fait avant on
gagne du temps on gagne du temps avec
trente salariés l'entreprise pense déjà
à s'agrandir en créant quinze nouveaux
emplois
à l'image de toute la zone suneor
désormais labellisé sites clés en main
encore en chantier et qui ne cesse de se
développer